bonsoir libyen bonsoir on commence ce
soir avec un gros plan sur un canton de
levens le canton de migennes oui c'est
une sainte
une situation emblématique de l'yonne
puisque dans l'yonne dans 20 cantons sur
21 le front national est au deuxième
tour et me gêne est une situation un
petit peu atypique dans l'yonne c'est un
ancien bastion communiste la gauche se
divise sur la ville les villages du
canton ont voté pour le front national
et au deuxième tour c'est donc le maire
ump de migennes qui affrontera le front
national du coup l'ancien maire
communiste qui était candidat appelle
lui à faire barrage au front national
reportage de nathalie d'affaires et
claude me gêne un petit village qui
devient au début du xxème siècle une
ville avec l'arrivée du chemin de fer
des milliers de cheminots travaillait
alors dans ce noeud ferroviaire
ils ne sont désormais plus qu'une
dizaine mais la ville reste marqué par
cette culture ouvrière elle a longtemps
été un bastion communiste
mais le scrutin de dimanche dernier
marque un tournant le front de gauche
est éliminée dès le premier tour tandis
que le front national sera lui au second
tour on fait le constat que s'il n'y
avait pas eu de candidat socialiste me
gêne et bien nous serions qualifiés pour
le deuxième tour
et même nous serions devant les autres
partis y compris devant la droite
libérale mais c'est vrai que nous avons
eu du mal à nous rassembler et puis il
ya cette déception et on nous met dans
le même sac
on dit bien toutes façons à gauche
scellé même si le front de gauche
continuent à faire des scores bien plus
important qu'ailleurs
un transfert des voix de l'extrême
gauche vers l'extrême droite semble se
dessiner les divisions à gauche et le
sentiment de désespérance pourraient
bien être les clés de cette progression
du fn y compris dans les quartiers les
plus populaires
ras le bol des gens sains à force de
taxer taxer taxer taxer les horizons
saturés alors ils veulent changer de
politique
résultat ce sera donc un duel ump front
national au second tour
pour enrayer cette montée du fn le maire
ump et candidat ou départementale mise
sur le terrain et l'amélioration du
quotidien des habitants
il prend acte de cet appel à changer la
façon de faire de la politique
bien entendu tout le monde est
responsable les gens en ont marre de
dire la politique de droite politique de
gauche tous pareils donc nous justement
par rapport à notre programme nous
travaillons justement sur le bien-être
des gens nous travaillons pour que l'on
puisse retrouver du travail qu'on puisse
avoir une espérance un fil conducteur de
développement de la commune et des
quartiers
dans le même temps le fn est absent du
terrain les deux candidats n'ont
quasiment fait aucune réunion publique
il met en avant des thématiques
uniquement nationales et le binôme de
candidats fn est également absent de ce
reportage
contactés ils ont refusé de s'exprimer
sur notre antenne et lyon toujours en
lien avec le fn on reste dans l'yonne
pour un événement inattendu aujourd'hui
oui on sait que on disait tout à l'heure
le front national sera présent deuxième
tour dans 20 cantons sur 21 en tête dans
dix cantons
on sait que l'ump est adepte du ni ni
sans consigne que la gauche a retiré son
candidat à pont-sur-yonne et que le
président sortant lui dei andré villiers
a comme la gauche appelé au front
républicain et bien andré villiers a
pris la tête de la bataille contre le
front national en organisant aujourd'hui
à germiny à la surprise générale une
réunion de tous les candidats de droite
et de gauche qui affronte le fn plus de
25 ans dida ont répondu présents des
candidats de droite et de gauche comme
il l'avait proposé ce qui a provoqué la
colère du front national qui est venue
protester devant le lieu de la réunion
avec d'ailleurs il faut le remarquer la
présence active de richard jacobs
pourtant exclu du front national
reportage complet d'ici la fin de ce
journal ou demain me disent ils
reportage n'est pas tout à fait prêt les
autres points chauds ligne en saône et
loire après la gauche y lire c'est la
droite qui est tenu aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse oui l'expression
est un peu forte conférence de presse
puisque vous allez le voir sur ces
images aucun candidat n'accompagnait à
paray le monial ce matin le leader de
l'opposition l'ump andré accary qui
s'est dit confiant il y à 29 cantons en
saône-et-loire le chiffre clef c'est
donc le 15
le premier camp à 15 quand on aura la
majorité dimanche soir je suis optimiste
on a je pense à premier tour qui a
marqué un désaveu profond déjà à la
majorité gouvernementale
c'est un signe fort vis-à-vis de ce
gouvernement et puis aussi cette
majorité départementale qui ne fait ni
plus ni moins que ce que le pari lui
commande donc je pense que on a un élan
positif
donc je suis optimiste mais il faudra
vraiment confirmé ce vote là au deuxième
tour et voter utile à les lions c'est la
tradition maintenant termine par
quelques tweets
oui mais très peu c'est un peu le calme
avant la tempête sur les réseaux sociaux
avec tout de même françois rebsamen qui
après avoir dit qu'il ne commentait pas
les chiffres du chômage les a commentées
pour demander de ne pas instrumentaliser
une nouvelle hausse la nouvelle hausse
de ce mois il pouvait toujours essayé
mais on ne voit pas vraiment pourquoi
l'opposition s'en seraient privés en
pleine campagne électorale est
immédiatement
françois sauvadet a dégainé en rappelant
que l'embellie n'avait pas duré
longtemps
c'est la campagne électorale merci les
liens